[Music]
it's a very interesting time now and boy
you don't know what's gonna happen I
know that I'm proud of it I know that
we've done everything we can
I really don't know how people are gonna
react to this thing this could be
anything from a flop to a moderate
single or something that it's beyond
what people's expectations are you never
know you never know good luck keeping on
we were in our own slipstream a feeling
like we were doing something a little
bit special and different but the full
circle of seeing that audiences were
reacting to it the way we had hoped they
would was powerful I had two dreams when
we started this little over 10 years ago
Morrill studio one was that I meant
working the other one was that we could
build something that was as expansive
and as experiential as what people who
read comic so viewers could get I had a
lot of faith and Kevin Feige and people
of Marvel you want to give them
everything you got cuz they're gonna
give everything that guy this was a
whole new journey by the first Avengers
but I thought oh wow I think we're onto
something here just seeing the
characters together there's something
viscerally awesome about it I think
that's why the minute Sam Jackson showed
up at the end of Iron Man 1 whether
people had very common or not who's that
what does that mean why is he here and
then Tony Stark appearing at the end of
the Incredible Hulk if I told you we
were putting a team together who's we
though it seemed like just the tiniest
of things compared to where we are now
but those were the foundations that led
us here the cutting edge concept behind
the Marvel Universe is this massive
organism of shifting parts and new ideas
how do we do this as a team Seraphin is
responsible for all of these amazing
actors and extras that we brought into
this I think after the first Avengers
people realized that this was not just
an ordinary comic-book movie that there
was really a lot of thought in a lot of
care and a lot of passion that's going
into each and every one of these film
and there's also some joy I think when
the actors are having fun and creating
these characters that audiences feel
that it's fulfilling that those
characters have just spoken to so many
people all over the world I love the
fact that we've been given the
opportunity to do something different
put our set of ideas forward and attack
your character again then hopefully
advance on that and bring something
unique to it each time it's wonderful to
be able to play this iconic character
that means so much to people and I
really have to think the audience's for
that because they embraced my portrayal
of her from the beginning final fitting
what do you think questions comments
concerns and allowed me to walk in
Natasha's shoes and kick ass in them too
I can tell you that each and every one
of us is so grateful
our lives are monumentally changed by
our involvement in this world to have
taken such an instrumental role in what
Marvel has done in the past ten years
it's just so incredibly meaningful to us
it's a cool experiment to be a part of
it's epic and classical these characters
are mythological characters in a lot of
ways I love all of you and I look
forward to seeing many of you as we
trudge this road of happy destiny it's
nice to look at how the legacy is living
on and these other movies and other
filmmakers I don't think this has ever
happened before in cinematic history of
all of these different franchises
colliding and all these storylines
they've started such a long time ago
have all woven together you guys as the
films have progressed with civil war and
now infinity war we're just gonna
continue to surprise people
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more
[Music]
you